Hey, David, do you consider yourself Hispanic?
What about Latino? What about an immigrant?
Uh, speaking of identity politics, uh, a question
about what is my identity?
This is like a really, really long thing.
Um, obviously I'm an immigrant in the sense
that I was born in Argentina and I immigrated
to the United States. There's this really
funny story that I'm reminded of. When I was
in middle school, um, there was an assembly
where they announced we are going to be giving
awards. My earpiece fell out here. Uh, we
are going to be giving awards for achievement
by Latino students. And all of a sudden they
say, David Pakman, please stand up. And I
was genuinely confused and I went home and
said to my parents, are we Latino in Spanish?
Of course the language I grew up in still
speak at home. Are We Latino? Are We Hispanic?
What's the difference? So here's my take on,
on this question, not that my identity matters,
but because it is the question that was asked.
I was born in Argentina and I grew up speaking
Spanish.
So I am clearly of what I call Hispanic culture
or Argentinian culture. That's the culture
I was raised in. Now, oftentimes there are
racial or ethnic questions tied up in these
questions. I was born to a Jewish family who
moved to Argentina from eastern Europe. Much
like many Jews moved to the United States
before World War II. So my ethnicity is Ashkenazi
Jewish in the United States. Aside from some
white nationalists, I guess Typically Ashkenazi
Jews are considered considered white when
it comes to their race or ethnicity. Had I
been born in the United States, I would clearly
be considered white by the definitions of
the census. To the extent that Jews are considered
white, so let's maybe dig in a little more
to the like Hispanic Latino thing. One version
of Hispanic versus Latino is that Hispanic
is everyone from Spanish speaking countries
in south and Latin America and that includes
Spain in Europe as well.
Uh, while Latino is all countries that are
physically in south and Central America, but
not Spain, which is in Europe and it's more
complex because you have places like Haiti
and Martinique and St Martin there, there's
sort of not Latino there. They're not really
Hispanic by any of these definitions and so
it starts to get a little bit complicated.
And then Brazil as a Portuguese speaking a
South American country also, sometimes it's
complex. I actually think that that's basically
a distraction for us. I'm definitely a Hispanic
immigrant to the u s from Latin America. I
am definitely ethnically Jewish and I pass
as white in the United States because I'm
ethnically Jewish and I learned English at
a young enough age so that I don't have an
accent other than some specific words that
slip out every once in awhile. I tend not
to use the term Latino because it does feel
a little bit tainted in the context of the
immigration debate.
But at the same time I feel like Hispanic
is very imprecise because you might be talking
about a Guatemalan immigrant or a family of
multigenerational wealth in Spain and politically
it's not just class, uh, in terms of money
politically, those are very, very different
things. And the idea that Hispanic encompass
encompasses all of it. Okay. It just seems
extraordinarily broad and imprecise anyway.
People have often seen me sort of mess with
my own identity when guests try to use my
perceived identity against me in some way.
And I sometimes would have joked with my girlfriend,
I'm not white, but the truth is I'm Hispanic
by culture. I'm ethnically Jewish, which is
white in the United States for all intents
and purposes. Uh, so I would say yes, I am
Hispanic. Uh, I think, I think I, I guess
I am Latino if I have to use that phrase,
that term.
Although I try not to use it because I feel
like it is stigmatized in the immigration
debate. And I am definitely an immigrant.
My passport will confirm that. Uh, we've got
a great bonus show planned for you today.
Please become a member at David pakman.com/membership
and also I am now streaming on twitch behind
the scenes, more casual streams with a lot
of audience participation. Follow me on twitch
at twitch.tv/david Pacman. And please, if
you have Amazon prime for free, you can subscribe
to my channel with twitch prime. It costs
you nothing, but it's a paid subscription
for us. Okay. Just Google.
How does subscribe to twitch prime and, um,
it'll take you if you'd be like a minute and
that it's a really, really great thing for
us. Speak to you on the bonus show in just
a couple of [inaudible], the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com.